kann ich kann gar nicht mehr atmen und
so hallo mein name ist herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
die fleißigen zuschauer sehen schon das
ist der gleiche hintergrund wie bei dem
golf renntag auf
ich sitze hier wieder auf meinem bett
was ihr im hintergrund wartet vielleicht
sieht man das mal so besser das ist das
ist mein bett ich habe mich hingesetzt
weil ich über etwas reden wollte ich
wollte nämlich heute eigentlich einen
gaming video hochladen
da stand sogar in meinem ablaufplan drin
eigentlich wollte ich ganz gediegen sims
zocken und das ganze halt aufnehmen und
hochladen allerdings ist mir gestern
beziehungsweise heute ein bisschen was
dazwischengekommen was immer noch
dazwischen ist das macht ja ganze ich
erzähle euch einfach mal was passiert
ist also jetzt gerade wenn ihr das video
seht ist dienstag gerade zum zeitpunkt
einer aufnahme ist es kurz vor zwei
mittag und gestern war ich noch zu hause
bei meiner familie und bin halt
irgendwann um 10 uhr morgens aufgewacht
und es war halt voll cooles wetter
draußen und ich einfach draußen gelegt
auf eine liege in der sonne und da bin
ich hatte mir ein gepennt und ab dann
eine stunde draußen gepennt bin dann
wieder reingegangen und wollte dann halt
irgendwie noch formen duschen gehen noch
kurzen liegestütze machen wenn er sich
einbildet dass das dann irgendwie
sportlich ist obwohl es eigentlich gar
nichts bringen und als ich dann diese
videos gemacht hat beziehungsweise
duschen gegangen bin hatte ich irgendwie
immer mehr rückenschmerzen und es kamen
wohl dadurch dass ich einfach als ich
draußen lag ein bisschen wind up
bekommen habe und ich dachte es war halt
wirklich warm aber ich hab den wind halt
nicht mit einberechnet deswegen war das
dann doch sehr scheiße jedenfalls habe
ich dann als ultra die rückenschmerzen
hat mich dann wieder das bett gelegt und
habe mich dann ein bisschen rum gelenkt
und sodann wurde dadurch wirklich alles
nur noch schlimmer zu beginn dieser
typischen rückenschmerzen die man hat
wenn man irgendwie zu bekommen hat oder
wenn man weiss ich mich irgendwie sich
falsch bewegt oder muskelkater vom
training oder so nur bei mir
dass man irgendwann schon so
rückenschmerzen dass ich wirklich nicht
mehr richtig atmen konnte ich konnte
nicht mehr richtig gerade stehen als ich
dann beispielsweise versucht habe mich
hinzusetzen oder wieder gerade
aufzustehen oder mich voll auf den bauch
zu legen oder auf dem rücken habe ich
immer so aber so richtige stöhn anfälle
bekommen oder so luft ausstößt weil das
richtig weh getan hat dann hat meine
mutter mehrheit irgendwann so einem
thema pflaster irgendwie auch wurden
gepackt dass es in wärme platz das ist
übrigens keine produktplatzierung ich
werde gleich noch ein zwei andere
produkte ostdeutsche wieder richtig weh
ich werde gleich noch ein paar andere
produkte nennen aber ich werde hierfür
nichts bezahlt also es ist einfach nur
geil wenn ich sagen würde ich sage halt
marken aber es ist es ist nichts hier
irgendwie gesponsert oder sorgt hat mir
das dann halt auch rücken geklatscht
meine mutter nicht dachten das hat das
ist so was sei wie so was halt relativ
kurzfristig ist so dass man das hat und
an diesem tag später wenn man darüber
geplant hat mit zum thema kerbler weiter
mein rücken theorie dass sie die ganze
zu aussetzer sondern dass ich vollauf
wahrscheinlich schneider und das kein
durchgängiges video ist so aber ich habe
ich habe probleme mit marten und
jedenfalls bin ich dann mit dem pflaster
noch auf meinem rücken geklebt wieder
nach hause gefahren in meine wohnung ich
sitze hier gerade wieder auf mein bett
und habe dann halt mich irgendwie sachen
ausgepackt und es hat auch die ganze
zeit wirklich noch sehr sehr doll weh
nach einer ausgepackt irgendwo
hingeschmissen hat mich einfach
irgendwie ins bett geworfen dann lag ich
irgendwie um halb drei im bett oder
sowie dann eingeteilt und eigentlich
hätte ich heute um 12 uhr hat mit
deswegen gegen gievenbeck haushalten 10
gestellt oder so allerdings habe ich am
morgen die elbe kommen dass unter
ausfällen aber das gibt es doch gar
nichts zur sache jedenfalls ich dann
irgendwie so über gedreht wollten auf
mein handy schon auf achse wollte mein
kompletter rücken ist gebrochen danach
dann da auf jeden fall so bei mir im
bett und hier bei mir im bett sagt noch
mal mein bett zeigen oder das ist mein
bett ich würde mich jetzt gar nach
hinten schmeißen oder drauf rum träumen
aber es ist mein rücken
jedenfalls hat meinen rücken dann
geknackt und ich dachte mir erstmal so
kay was soll das denn jetzt ist jetzt
alles wieder okay und dann wollte
aufstehen und dann ging es halt echt
überhaupt nicht klar es war heute morgen
wirklich der fall dass ich nicht mal
richtig sprechen konnte das ist übrigens
alles hier kein fake irgendwie nach also
ich denke mir das hier nicht aus ich
würde
am liebsten gerade irgendwie 100000 euro
bezahlen dafür dass mein rücken wieder
heile ist weil das tut echt unfassbar
wehrlein als ich die sind allein wenn
ich diesen beruf mache mein kompletter
wird mir schon weh weil diese das ja
schon wenn sich meine stimme verändert
wenn mich irgendwie alleine im wiso nach
hinten greifen sich die schulterblätter
in das ist alle hätten ihre schmerzen
ich meine es gibt bestimmt youtuber die
dann aufwachen und dann sehen sie haben
totale schmerzen dann direkt ne kamera
nehmen und sagen jo freuen ich habe ja
total die schmerz und halten das
irgendwie auf kamera fest das war bei
mir leider nicht der erste gedanke
sondern ich habe mich erst mal darum
gekümmert dass ich irgendwie nicht
sterben es hört sich jetzt krass an aber
es war nicht so ich konnte nicht tief
einatmen ich habe eine ganze sogar art
und ich weiß ja immer das gehört aber
wirklich so versucht mal dass ihr so
habe ich die ganze zeit geraten
ich konnte nicht richtig sprechen das
war wirklich es war totale horror heute
morgen dann habe ich halt irgendwie nach
halben stunde es geschafft mich
irgendwie richtig aufzuhängen bisher
irgendwie zu strecken bisschen
rumzulaufen kurz irgendwie wissen wasser
zu trinken und ab dann halt wir duscht
und nach dem duschen am kanal gedacht
okay luca ein termin hier bekommst du
jetzt ihn nicht bei irgendeinem arzt
weil ich habe schon vorher im internet
geguckt erstand wenn man was akutes hat
muss man trotzdem mit wartezeiten von
bis zu zwei monaten rechnen
das hat echt die chance einer großstadt
ab danach noch hin und her telefoniert
mit ein paar kliniken allerdings sind
das alles nur so für privatpatienten und
ich bin halt gesetzlich
krankenversichert deswegen attacke und
dann habe ich irgendwann mein handy
genommen hat das einfach mal auf kamera
festgehalten wie es mir dann ging also
jetzt kommt nach aufnahme kurz nach dem
duschen glaube ich ich habe jetzt gerade
geduscht beim duschen ging alles klar
also als heißes wasser drüber lief so
war alles gut ich merke als
zwischendurch mal noch so ein paar
stiche irgendwie enten so zwischen den
schulterblättern so als er mit einer so
richtig lange nadel irgendwie rein und
würde jetzt kann ich beispielsweise
sogar richtig reden wenn ich diesen
anderen drücke ich mich jetzt hinsetzen
dann ist das aller e klasse ist und zwar
wenn ich so sitze geht es noch aber wenn
ich dann eine aufrechte position wir
dann kann ich kann gar nicht mehr atmen
und so es ist jetzt gerade auf jeden
fall schon
viel besser geworden als das heute
morgen weil wir heute morgen kann ich
gar nicht richtig stehen dann bin ich
die ganze zeit
jetzt kann die nie mehr so an dass opel
auch heute morgen konnte ich quasi nur
irgendwie so rumlaufen wenn so die
webseite auf mittlerweile kann ich nicht
mehr so gehen außen kommt dass wir jetzt
gerade kann ich nur noch komplett gerade
laufen
ich halte ich würde ich bin aufgestanden
und habe zwei stunden mich nur um
gequält hat mich dann irgendwann die
dusche gestellt das heißt das wasser
wenn mein rücken lief und wärme am start
habe alles übrigens chillig werde die
haare geföhnt und mich irgendwie
angezogen dann kam diese aufnahme hier
ich bin fertig mit duschen und mein okay
das ist dann wieder sehr weh getan ich
sitze gerade hier auf meinem bett und
das problem meine uhr lädt da vorne
gerade deswegen gerade aber ich habe
gerade echt vorhin kurz gedacht okay als
ich durch die wohnung laufen wenn so ein
bisschen ich muss nicht mehr zum arzt
aber jetzt gerade wieder total arten
probleme und ich weiß nicht ich hier
jetzt mal aufzustehen
doch es ging auch das getan was machen
ich hatte es auch heute morgen schon
dass ich schießen musste und das einfach
nicht hingekriegt habe ich weiß nicht ob
das klug heitz gerade dem video gesagt
hat ich kann halt nicht mehr reden dass
du und ich jetzt zum arzt also zur
apotheke erst mal ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich das schon gesagt habe und zwar habe
ich heute morgen versucht zu niesen und
zu husten und ich hatte das noch nie
einen geht man ja so wenn man so alt
und dann muss man halt nichts aber wenn
mir was ich wann dieser bewegung diesen
hut ab da einfach so gestoppt weil man
rücken hat das irgendwie blockiert das
war quasi irgendwie so wenn man und dann
auf einmal sagt die rücken so eine
steuer halt dein maul jetzt ein wenig
haltverbote hier nebenan gegangen und
waren irgendwie zehn minuten später
wieder hier ich bin gerade von einer
apotheke gekommen
der typ hat
abc wärmepflaster totale schmerztherapie
gegeben dass er sich vier euro gekostet
es tut immer noch unglaublich wie ich
kann jetzt nicht irgendwie solche
bewegungen machen oder so was das
unfassbar wenig vorkommt sagen es ist
besser geworden aber es kommt als
zwischendurch mal so stich und man kann
sogar nicht mehr reden und man kann gar
nicht atmen alter ist es ist echt
ich war tief einatmen das geht ja auch
nicht also was brasilia verträge
passiert ist ich bin rein gekommen und
der typ war davon ja der typ von der
apotheke halt wer auch sonst und ich
habe ihm halt mein komplettes problem
geschildert ich habe ihm halt das alles
gesagt was ich euch gesagt haben er
meint er hat für mich entweder
schmerzmittel oder sonne voltaren salbe
oder so ein wärmekissen und ich habe
mich dann halt blöderweise für das
wärmekissen entschieden meinte dass
wärmekissen sei super cool und ich soll
das man kaufen und deswegen habe ich
vier euro 20 für so ein scheiß kissen
bezahlt ja wieder der wohnung war habe
ich halt erstmal noch so einen kleinen
test gefahren ich las die kamera einfach
mal erstehen um mich zu filmen wie es
aussieht wenn ich aufstehe also erstmal
ist mich hin wo mein okay okay sitzen
tue ich und jetzt stehe ich wieder auch
so sieht außerdem auf stimme mein gott
ok ich stehe ja ich habe mich dabei
gefilmt wie ich mich hinsetzen wieder
aufstehen ja ich bin dummheit
ich bin luca dann als ich ins bad
gegangen bin und mir dieses
wärmepflaster mal genauer anschauen
wollte alter schwede
ich habe gerade diese scheiß verpackung
von einem scheiß drauf gemacht und das
nur eins laster 22 14 zentimeter das ist
dieses ding hier also ich dachte wenn
jetzt fünf stücke sowie arena oder war
wirklich nur ein wärmepflaster drin was
man vier bis zehn stunden anwenden kann
das heißt theoretisch muss ich mir alle
zehn stunden ein neues wärmepflaster für
vier euro 20 kaufen herzlichen
glückwunsch medizinindustrie als
mediziner austria arznei industrie oder
dann haben das nächste problem und zwar
schon auf der rückseite sie benötigen
zum anbringen eine zweite person
wo soll ich denn jetzt die zweite person
her nehmen sich aus als hätte ich
freunde mein gott
die zum heiligen fig soll ich das auf
meinen rücken kriege noch mal alles
klebt oh mein gott okay wenn ich aber
ich hab's blöd hänge klebt top es hat
noch nie jemand bekommt darum dinge
aufgespielt hat dann auf jeden fall
hingekriegt mir das ding alleine
aufdrücken zu kleben und ich habe jetzt
gerade auch immer noch drauf eine stunde
später und ich muss euch sagen jetzt
sollte nicht wärmepflaster heißen
sondern einfach vulkan
das ding ist heiß wie lava es ist echt
so ich habe mich darauf dem rücken auf
meinem bett gelegt ich halte das nicht
aus weil es so heiß ist
ich habe angst dass ich irgendwelche
verbrennungen er habe danach lag ich für
sie einfach nur noch rum und das
schon dann habe ich mich irgendwann
aufgerappelt und hab das jetzt wirklich
heute noch aufgenommen ich hatte mich
eigentlich gesagt ich war schon kurz
davor zu bieten und bei snap chat und
instagram zu teilen so jungbäume mir
gehts echt scheiße heute kommt kein
video aber jetzt habe ich mich trotzdem
einmal hingesetzt und ich meine sitzen
geht gerade ich meine dieses pflaster es
wird das muss ich wirklich sagen das war
es jetzt quasi vom heutigen video so ein
bisschen als konnte jetzt zum schluss
freunde schätzt eure gesundheit ich
weiter sollte jetzt wahrscheinlich zumal
wenn ich das sage aber ich habe mir
beispielsweise schon zweimal das rechte
handgelenk gebrochen einmal beim fußball
und einmal bei einem fahrradunfall ich
habe beide male in gips bekommen und
musste dann immer mit einer mülltüte um
den armen duschen und muss mir mit links
die zähne putzen und essengehen nicht
richtig ich konnte fast gar nichts
machen und als hier gibt's wieder abkam
war es für mich so ein ultra krasser
moment wusste hier alles funktioniert
wieder und es ist gerade auch mit meinem
rücken weil ich sage euch werde ich
dieses pflaster abnehmer und dann
eventuell morgen oder übermorgen der
alles in ordnung ist ich hoffe dass
alles wieder in ordnung ist und dass ich
nicht irgendwie noch eine notaufnahme
oder zum arzt fahren muss dann wird das
für mich auch irgendwie der krasseste
moment sein weiß okay ich bin wieder
gesund deswegen freunde schätzt wirklich
dass ihr gesund sein
damit wäre ich auch heute das heutige
video
es geht mir gerade schon wieder besser
also ihr seht schon ich kann schon
wieder ein bisschen besser reden ich
weiß nicht wie es ist wenn ich jetzt auf
stehe das kann ich eigentlich live mal
eben machen
okay es geht ihr seht gottmann pulli ich
kann stehen ich kann mich bewegen ich
kann mich wieder so ein bisschen bereden
recht ich denke es kommt einfach mit der
zeit allerdings wenn irgend einer von
euch gleich arzt ist oder der partner
oder so könnte da vielleicht mal fragen
es ist halt kein hexenschuss oder das
ist im oberen rückenbereich und es ist
irgendwie durch durch wind und falsch
gesenkt und so nicht ist es wirklich so
wenn ich die schulter nach hinten machen
kann ich schlecht atmen und so also
keine ahnung ich denke ehrlich gesagt
dass keiner von euch arzt ist denn euch
solche sachen gefallen will ich mich
meine bewertung freuen ich hab das ja
jetzt auch schon mit dem horrorfilm
video gemacht was ich euch hier mal
verlinkt da habe ich ja auch irgendwie
immer sache mit dem iphone gefilmt als
es quasi so wirklich passiert ist und
dann
in dem video das zusammengefasste die
szenen eingeblendet das ist dann halt
nicht so einen block von dem tag was ich
gemacht habe sondern mehr so ich wilde
sachen und schneide die nacht herein und
kommentiert das ganze nochmal also wenn
euch so was gefällt und die das öfter
volk will ich mich da selber eine
bewertung freund sonst sieht er jetzt
hier eher sachen eingeblendet das ist
eine neue abspann funktion die ich mal
testen wollte da ist irgendwie glaube
ich der shop und ebenso anderes video
also ich weiß auch dass gerade
funktioniert bei youtube aber als auch
komplett egal ich freue mich dass ihr
euch das video bis zum ende angeschaut
habt und ich hoffe dass es meinem rücken
besser geht demnächst und das dann
wieder normale gaming videos kommen
können und ich mich wirklich haben einen
pc setzen kann
aber jetzt könnte ich mir erst mal kurz
eine auszeit